[Applause]
[Music]
El Salvador is a small country in fact
it's the smallest country in all of
Central America but that's only
geographically the country has 6.5
million inhabitants a population that's
larger than Panama Costa Rica Belize or
Nicaragua that's a large population
especially when you consider that
emigration from the country is common
according to various sources some three
to four million Salvadorians are living
abroad with many living in the United
States
Don't Tell Trump disgusting I don't want
to talk about emigration is ever popular
with thousands of Salvadorians
each year packing up their suitcases and
taking a chance on a better future
somewhere else if this rate of
emigration from El Salvador maintains
itself then there might soon be more
Salvadorians and living outside El
Salvador than there are living inside it
so now you might be wondering why are so
many people so keen to leave this
country or you might not be wondering
that I mean we did have to choose a
title for this video but anyway so let's
have a look at why so many people are
leaving this country
yes it is true that El Salvador is a
very poor country that economics is not
the only reason that people are leaving
now before we get into details on what
exactly is causing this Exodus let me
give you a quick bit of information El
Salvador is a tropical country where you
can find stunning beaches like these as
well as magnificent nature reserves like
this one as well as amazing cultural
remains and in 2017 this is a year in
which the country should be celebrating
2017 marked the 25th anniversary of the
peace agreements which put an end to the
bitter and cruel civil war which lasted
more than 12 years and caused more than
70,000 deaths this conflict was between
the National Armed Forces and the
so-called Farah bunzo Marti National
Liberation Front a left wing
paramilitary group which counted on the
support of the Cuban government
interestingly after the peace agreements
this guerrilla group who became a
political party and today they have the
presidency of the Republic quite the
remarkable change in sterile operations
yeah or what it is oh it's done it games
yet it's not fighting yet
now while this 25th anniversary should
be a reason for celebration it's pretty
hard to celebrate when you look at the
current situation that El Salvador finds
itself in the violence the 11th of
January 2017 was a normal Wednesday
where nothing extraordinary happened
absolutely nothing so let me explain
that day ended with a death toll of the
0 in El Salvador and yes van non-events
was actually front-page news the reason
for this being newsworthy is that al
salvador has become one of the most
dangerous countries in the world now to
give you an idea of how dire the
situation is consider this in 2015
6670 murders were registered that is to
say there were 105 murders of every
100,000 inhabitants
this is the highest of any country in
the world which is not currently a war
zone this number is really truly
terrifying and is perhaps best
illustrated with a comparison if this
figure were applied to the UK which
means there were 70,000 murders a year
in the country and what's the real
figure for the UK well it's a touch more
than 500 murders
that's 140 times less in 2016 the
figures were a bit lower but there was
still four thousand murders registered
this is madness there have been Wars
well as people have died oh and believe
me murder is far from the only serious
crime going down in our Salvador
kidnapping extortion theft they're all
worryingly common so with all this great
news well who's up for a holiday to El
Salvador like no one oh what a surprise
now given all of this information it's
probably no surprise to you that
according to recent surveys it's been
indicated that nearly half of the
population of El Salvador wants to leave
and it's really clear to see that this
violence has consequences and this isn't
just a fear of crime being committed
against you directly but it also affects
the standard of living of all people in
the country now according to the
Salvadorian central bank violence costs
around 4 billion u.s. dollars a year and
you know what that's not really that
surprising I mean after all if you want
to invest their money in a country where
you can be killed at pretty much any
time do I believe me well how about this
al Banaras foreign investment is the
lowest in all of Central America even
regular people are at risk in El
Salvador in fact the statistics show
that you're more likely to be murdered
as a bus driver rather than a policeman
in the country in the last five years
alone street gangs have killed almost
700 bus drivers
violence in the region now it is known
globally that Latin America does have a
serious problem with violence and crime
according to a report from the British
consulting firms various Maplecroft
Latin America is the region where you
have the highest risk of having a
violent crime committed against you
indeed six of the world's 10 most
violent countries are actually in this
region
[Music]
more incredible than that though is the
fact that one in three homicides that
occur every year globally take place in
Latin America even within this dangerous
environment the northern triangle
countries of Central America really
takes a biscuit this area is formed of
El Salvador Honduras and Guatemala and
it is by far the most dangerous area on
the continent in fact when you don't
consider war zones it's actually the
most dangerous region in the world in
these countries which are relatively
small 200,000 people have been murdered
since 2004
[Music]
when you think about the reality of
these numbers is pretty easy to see why
people want to leave you can't walk the
street safely at night or wear a watch
or a necklace or start a business
without having to pay some criminal
organization it kind of sucks so the
question that must be on your mind right
now is but why is there so much violence
[Music]
rap trafficking and murder good question
that's probably on your mind now is just
why is there so much violence now the
reality is these countries in Central
America have not always been such
dangerous places it could even been
considered relatively peaceful until
about 20 years ago at least on an
individual level but this all started to
change by the end of the 80s and 90s for
two reasons
drug trafficking and Mari
[Music]
[Applause]
first of all deep drug trafficking this
is a serious problem in the region every
year 22 million Americans use drugs and
most of them come from South America the
drug cartels are making an absolute
fortune from this obviously this isn't
anything new but this activity has
evolved over the years and has
continually found ways to operate a
spite pressure from law enforcement the
persecution of the famous Colombian drug
cartels led to a shift in route of the
drugs coming to the u.s. previously it
went Colombia to the Caribbean islands
to Florida now there's a new route that
goes through Central America and this is
the first big problem Central America
has become a sort of sanctuary for new
Mexican drug cartels from Central
America they can organize their business
hide drugs and take refuge from justice
whenever needed so now you're probably
getting the idea experts have calculated
that 80% of the drugs used in the US has
to go through Honduras and this has led
to an extraordinary amounts of violence
in that region and now for the second
major problem the maras for those of you
don't know them the Mara's asks street
gangs that engage in all kinds of
criminal activities like seth's murder
or extortion then and those are usually
young people and their organization is
relatively horizontal meaning that they
don't have much of an organized
hierarchy they organize in individual
criminal cells which work quite
independently from one another and do
take note here because it is estimated
that in these three countries alone
damaris have around 70 to 100 thousand
members noise famous of these
organizations are Salva cuca and Barry
o-18 and both usually fight against each
other over the control of different
territories I think in violence the
situation is complex many strategies
have been use to try and solve the
problem and they have all failed
however two initiatives have been put
into practice lately in order to change
the reality of these countries and
achieve safety for their citizens the
first is known as the traditional task
force this is a security apparatus
formed by police officers intelligence
experts and special units of the three
countries that we've mentioned the end
of this group is to fight street gangs
drug trafficking and/or
crime regardless of borders or things
the group receives support training and
financing from the United States the
idea of this is clear as Quan Orlando
Hernandez the president of Honduras
likes to say we are going to give them a
taste of their own medicine the second
initiative is linked to the first and it
is known as the Alliance of prosperity
this was launched by the Obama
administration and it expects to improve
the living conditions and the
competitiveness of these countries its
main goal is to create jobs and
essential infrastructure in order to
reverse the terrible current situation
to start Washington has already
committed to spend 750 million dollars
in order to support these initiatives
but the question is really is there any
hope and the answer is well the sort of
has to be matter Selva true ha has
already communicated that they are
willing to negotiate their own
dismantling but only time will tell if
it's successful so that's our view on
the region here at visual politics but
we would love to know what you think do
you think these countries will manage to
get rid of their criminal elements will
the plans set by Washington succeed at
all I'd love to know what you think and
you can use the comments to do that and
unfortunately because of the growth of
this channel we can't answer all at the
comments that please do know that we do
read them all and as always if you like
this video please do hit that thumbs up
button below and don't forget to
subscribe for brand new videos every
Monday and Thursday and as always I'll
see you next time
[Music]